non vi ha messo in prigione
o noi non abbiamo mica paura
benvenuti solita storici oggi nuovissime
ski promo paura tacerò bros dovrebbe
scappare da questa qua mi mari che tipo
un insegnante una maestra cattivo che
bei denti mio
profilo è stato mai utile se volete
vedere a tre che per roma e soprattutto
altre schepp rompa rota mettetevi comodi
pre di bob corn mi sta guardando
bruttissimo sei pronto ad essere
mangiato con i suoi denti appuntiti
dove siamo in una scuola è infestata che
è il caso il suo la nuova libreria di
miss maria proposito di scuole infettate
avete già preso storico lavoro che a
scuola di mettere
avete scritto che avete già preso che
visto tantissime avete già finito e
incredibile se non ce l'avete ancora
fari spenti non potete non averlo
prendetelo seguito vi lascio il link in
descrizione scrivetemi se l'avete presa
e mandano c'è una foto anche tante volte
si svelerà vita
adoro questa allora non apprendono mi
piaccia freddo ma dov'è e alle spalle
arrivata così che brutta sembrò granny
però più brutta è un po più carina di
credito e
dove devo andare
devo prendere questi libri forse ti
illumina però ho preso un libro davvero
aspettarmelo qualcuno spiaccicato
aiuto
vabbè io continuo andare quando allora
sei riuscito a prenderlo questo libro è
pressoché apriamo e adesso solo uno ce
n'era sì io dai sbrigati il grigio tocca
la porta ok vai via
[Risate]
che preso no mi ha messo in prigione
ma io pure sono state quella porta ma
mia anch'io sono in prigione
ciao siamo qui a almeno stiamo assieme
meno male piace una chioma è che tutta
la vostra mari già lasciato la chiave
dentro
tutto appare addio bari sono rimasto
bloccato
a freddo l'occhio di via ma c'è qualcuno
che possiamo liberare abbiamo una spada
no non c'è nessuno se lo spam
guardiamo ad affettare barriera che
voglio una gamba con tutti i vari mostri
quasi uno scheletro uno scheletro fatto
che siamo finiti
ok è infestata di guardia ma non lo è ma
cos'altro mi ha tolto la spada lo
scheletro e adesso anzi me preso solo un
libro su di ex c1 sul libro però non me
lo fa prendere
tutti i libri attento non farti
spiaccicare a noi questo caso non
spiaccicare ma infilzare il risultato
fissato peccato che non abbia voluto
vitale infilzato tifos piedi scritto
aiutami tu amerete non c'è scritto aiuto
di qua del muro
qualcuno è stato
qualcuno è finito molto male da soli ora
ho preso e via evviva aiuto
adoro questi bella infatti i castelli lo
sapete ormai lo sapete io adoro le
ambientazioni dei castelli e capitare
che si è sfracellato
dice vado un po strano c'era quel
liquido radioattivo lì
chi è che sia
sposate mi piace per portare fortuna a
svitare lasciate un mi piace come
vediamo se funziona via lasciatemi
pianista mi piace vediamo sta
funzionando ragazzi funzionato
[Musica]
divertente scritto torna indietro prima
che sia troppo tardi ma no noi non
abbiamo mica paura
devo 20 scritto scappa
adoro le case infestate dietro l'idea
che tutto ciò non ti giravi scappa e un
labirinto qua dobbiamo trovare un'uscita
dietro di me
è troppo tardi c'è scritto qui no
meno male non è velocissimo e un cuore
le fasi
quale strada destra
sei sicuro o vabbè io cioè era stata
sistemata era giusta non ci credo bravi
aspetta perché ancora non sappiamo se la
strada giusta
e ora magari magari troviamo un vicolo
cieco
ok meno male non siamo di non fare
ok riproviamo cerchiamo di non mettere
in vicoli ciechi
c'è scritto la maglieria glicina quindi
la strada era giusta questa più che ho
preso e tranne l'ultima allora andiamo
di qua finché non arriva andrè di qua e
ansia
destra le dietro di te c'è scritto
ancora non la vedo per fortuna non ne ho
preso un'altra strada
chi siede senso c'è scritto un
pochettino
mondo dimmi che la strada giusta non so
della strada giusta
sono rimasto bloccato sul successore
sono riuscito a scappare vero quando è
coabitare finalmente un mezzo mezz'ora
ad arrivare un po più e ora che superi
pure parla che ti aspetta a casa impari
a svelarvi prati giu spiaccicato che
anche in questo caso bruciati azzurro
già perché il pavimento della va c'è ma
guardate questa ambientazione ma quanto
ebbe
adoro l'escape room con le ambientazioni
così elaborate e belle
evviva lo prendo io siamo tre libri di
dieci perché non me lo fa prendere
attento non toccare queste punte di lava
figura di no
sì qualcuno è caduta qui tutti dovrà
evitare
voglio vederlo
sono già arrivato al prossimo checkpoint
a raggiungere vitale deve adoperarlo
cece dove crisi scappare fra cellino
raggiunto
ei siamo nelle viscere della terra siamo
nei sotterranei del castello un altro
libro ei quattro libri di 10 quando
tornerà l'insegnante mari secondo me non
ce la fa a passare in questi cunicoli
strette
dove stiamo siamo tornati dentro al
caffè un libro libro 5 e ora
attenta barroso
bellissimo anche faveri colpo harry
potter che c'è di brasil secolo ho fatto
pure una cabrio
ecco vitale
vediamo se ce la fa
e certo che se lo faccio
come fatta ok dove va beh la
ghigliottina te ha preso basta è ancora
vivo non lo so anch'io che ho fatto ma
non abbiamo neanche visto essere una
ghigliottina o non altro la neri
dobbiamo salutare in questa porta ma
perché non salta la leggenda perché ti
girano la storta dove dobbiamo andare
dice che dobbiamo andare di qua segui me
che non ho capito acqua guarda dobbiamo
andare la porta che facendo o forse la
porta è chiusa andiamo a prendere la
rete mi dicono di andare nella di navi e
io prendo la dinamica e poi vediamo la
porta è chiusa allora dobbiamo trovare
un modo per aprirla ho messo la dinamite
già vicino alla porta
dobbiamo prendere tutte le versioni
fatelo pure sfiga vaio una commessa ok
ne mancano due
musichetta e un po in fretta bene allora
ci siamo quasi a mo 30
ok revocato loro non vedo l'ora di far
esplodere la porta io sto mettendo
l'ultima stessa è esplosa la porta da me
ne manca ancora uno ecco fatto
fa vita e mi ha superato
bravo anche io ti ho aspettato a tentare
allora qui c'è del fumo quindi forse ci
farà andare veloce qualcosa pizzino un
brutto presentimento
la musica si aspetta di civiltà che
succede è preso mismari ma dove
bisogna stare soprattutto in questo
labirinto non girarsi perché lei è di
tipo ai luoghi che si segue nelle
tubature esatto dopo questa volta nomi 0
grazie a girare le condizioni di vita di
fatiche lo sapevate voluti coppia o
sbagliato strada
e ho preso qualche punto si appena
ricominciato
e ora
chi ce lo porta a porta da bloccava no è
difficilissimo
devi seguire le frecce si sbagli ti
prende
sì riuscita pero io sono ancora bloccato
qui non so dove andare troppo
e paura presto scappiamo so perché è ok
no niente avevano visto la versione
ranocchio è veramente di molto difficile
di prendere la mira qui c'è una leva
premiamo la vediamo che succede
si è aperta una borsa dobbiamo andare là
presto usiamo e ma dove devo saltare
adesso dobbiamo un po allontanato ed è
giusto nota è caduto poverino
vitale buffa ok e ora dobbiamo scendere
qua come quindi devo riprendere la leva
non sto controllo se la portò aperto
dove
c'è un libro ii piano piano piano non
cadere è fatta la riva del aggiunto
fini come quanto stiamo in alto
allora la porta mi sembra
bello che stavo casa dietro stai molto
attento a non cadere non c'è problema il
prima
non avevo visto che fanno capo un pezzo
di tubo ma io non mi dire che devo
rifare tutto ma chi è che ha messo il
libro lison su quel tubo lo show dove di
questo io la votiamo no la porta è
aperta per ok si riparte da capo però è
difficilissimo stare in equilibrio su
questi tubi
tu le prese dei prossimi 7 10 anche
se lo vicino alla porta
attento
e viva voce l'hai fatto bravo o c'è un
gioco alla squadra ora
trattata ok allora questo poi troviamo
questo brava
no quindi sono tre di fila a destra 1 o
4 6 3 ok
trono e quindi ci sarà l'ultimo quale
sarà vediamo se c'è un trucchetto no non
mi fate parlare perché con questo
che
io ti vedo giocare perché mi sono
sforzato e babel è ancora vivo ma che
bello e un bug
e adesso
quindi era quello
dell aiuto non ci cado niente ok avete
rispettato un po di tutto un affettato
ok tra foto vediamo vita però
aveva apprezzato allora vediamo da
evitare puoi farcela contiamo su di te
lasciatevi piace per portare fortuna
vitale e vediamo se funziona
guarda come sto passando
aiuto sono troppo forte
perché sei caduto no non sono kabul non
lo so di aver visto che se caduta ma
possiamo saltare questa traccia c'è un
teschio laggiù abili incoraggiante
attento il pavimento e lava la musica
sembra quella di g
star iii sul teschio ma un teschio
gigante tipo qualcosa mi dice che tra
poco punterà a miss maria
c'è manolo anche qui viene il libro non
l'avevo visto sì mancano solo due lepri
wow che successo
siamo riusciti a uscire dalla scuola
però c'è un libro c'è scritto pericolo
caduta o tranquilla di riprendermi il
libro qui ok però che non dobbiamo
buttarci da qua no figura invece penso
proprio di sì
sopravviveremo no guarda c'è uno scivolo
qua ma dove
sono i pipistrelli o figlio
ok devi scendere piano piano per una
sfracellato
piano piano allora forse ho capito che
riproviamo dobbiamo scendere piacciono
ci sono degli scalini aipo quindi puoi
quanto impiantare niente mi sono sfogato
paiono però ma c'è una tavola e poi
allora forse da qui si scende vediamo un
tocco
non capisco a ecco devi guardare bene
c'è un'altra tavola passo ma
noi dobbiamo prendere i badge
penso di aver capito dice un'altra vabbè
ho
visto scivolare allora c'è una tavola
purtroppo buio non si vede e aspetta ma
io sono già ci sono i pipistrelli che
salvano ma io sono giorni sono già
arrivati sì mi sono sfracellato che non
mi ha salvato che adesso che riesce ad
arrivare due a tut ti vedo ti vedo
dall'alto dal basso cioè forse si sono
forse questa volta mi sfracello anzi
meglio non dirlo
le altre tavole ma
vi al menti si tratta adesso cerchiamo
di non essere spiaccicati dalle mappe si
dai liberi se lo fa
chi conviene stare di lato a camminare
di lato così almeno le vendite fermo di
fermo di una video giallo ma si è
tornata in mente
per una
equa possa prendere una pausa ok guarda
ok qua possa passare
dopo questo
miss maria si è proprio qua dobbiamo
affrontarla
ora prendiamo subito il belgio è appreso
si legge è così cosa sono i pupazzetti
che c'è chi brucia qualcosa non so
inoltre mi
sono preso questo come effetto il
proprio aspetto a ma questo non fa nella
spada
questo mese li vedi qui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri vidi la casa
squadre preferite è pure visioni ciao